welcome everybody few things i wanted to
get to this week i didn't have the
chance and now i do so let's do it there
is a quaint little hypothesis from my
pillow ceo and founder mike lindell
about the forthcoming election and as
many of you know mike pillow as we know
him or even just pillow for short
he is determined to grind to us
to a screeching halt the 2022 and 2024
elections
and his new idea
is
something about voting machines and he's
explaining it to steve bannon and it's
the blind leading the blind and i can't
tell whether bannon believe this this
stuff or whether either of them do but
take a look at the new strategy
this is wild it's live link up with
these tech technology people that you
can actually go and get it to individual
states and get injunctions to basically
shut down the machines to be used in the
2020 midterm elections and state
elections right sir
yeah the 2022 that's correct steve and
in any elections it would be over uh
we're gonna get it is over
injunctions and it's with no machines
because they cannot do elections
accurately and they can and they can be
manipulated it wouldn't be accurate 100
percent they say you know they did it
they're caught now they're guilty it's
in violation of fund of fundamental
rights to vote under
42-usc
1983
a violation of equal protection and also
due process we are starting with seven
states immediately
uh we're going we're going we're going
to get to every state and uh every of
course you're going to get pushed back
and stuff but every state
the people that's by the way you know
who the stand who has the standing all
the voters steve yeah so
this there's a funny aspect to this and
pillow is obsessed with machines and
he's trying to remember when he said he
was gonna sue every machine we're doing
a class action lawsuit against all
machines
that is one of the funniest clips my
espresso machine has gone into hiding
because of this forthcoming lawsuit it
is absolutely horrified it may be
completely shut down the funny thing
about this is it's cartoonish
it's it's off the wall it's kooky it's
it's all these different things
but
the precedent that or the the rules the
law that pillow cites
just doesn't have anything to do with
the use of voting machines he when he
talks about 42 us code 1983 that's a
section called civil action for
deprivation of rights and when you read
it it says every person um
and anyone who is deprived of a right
has the ability to seek recourses and
you know gives you standing
the fact that voting machines are used
doesn't deprive anyone of rights you
would have to demonstrate that and of
course pillow and others have failed to
demonstrate that the mere existence of
voting machines deprives someone of the
right to vote which is the the right
that we're talking about here
in addition to this
um
there's kind of the other side of it
which is if you got rid of all machines
if you if you did that
and we simply had a universal vote by
mail everybody mails in a paper ballot
and its paper ballots counted one by one
and then recounted you you count them
and then you recount them okay
i would be fine with that and it
wouldn't be particularly good for
republicans
um they love to claim oh the left would
use mail-in ballots for fraud and all of
it there's no evidence of that and we
saw that in 2020 they claimed it but
there was not actually any evidence of
it
it would take a really long time and
we've gotten used to well we want
results sooner than that
but i would be fine with universal vote
by mail and count every ballot by hand
and have a paper trail i'm okay with
that and i think many on the left would
be
the reason they are trying to mess with
the machines so to speak
is uh both self-serving and due to
things they misunderstand as as is often
the case with much of what uh
republicans do so does pillow believe
this that he's about to shut down all
these elections because they're getting
rid of all the machines does steve
bannon it's hard to believe that anyone
would believe it
at the same time they've been saying it
for a year and a half so i don't know
you be the judge
marjorie taylor green a radical
republican congresswoman who has been
kicked off of all of her committees and
fined for
refusing to wear masks on the floor of
the house to to high heaven she's been
fine to high heaven at this point
she is now lying that joe biden is
paying tick-tock influencers now as is
almost always the case sometimes they
make up
nonsense whole cloth like when she
talked about jewish space lasers or
lasers as lindsey graham called them
that was completely made up
but sometimes there's like a kernel of
something and it is true
that the biden administration
met with tick-tock influencers
there was
rampant rampant russian propaganda on
tick-tock
and tick-tock is a growing platform we
now are on to we're taking tick tock
seriously because we're having such
explosive growth there nearly a hundred
thousand followers already i think tick
tock has grown faster than any platform
we've ever been on for us tic tocs it's
growing and so the biden white house met
with a bunch of tick-tock influencers
they didn't pay them they didn't pay
them and marjorie taylor-green
says that not only were they paid they
were paid off and paid off has an
additional pejorative connotation that
it's
you know people are being given money to
say specific things they don't believe
take a listen to this
and what is the white house doing as the
world slides dangerously close to
devastating world war paying off
tick-tock influencers to lie for them
more concerned with favorable headlines
from the washington post and the new
york times than avoiding world war
more concerned with social media likes
than protecting american jobs and
families so of course none of that is
true
uh and there are numerous reports about
this
uh fortune magazine biden is using tick
tock to fight back against russia's
reported use of influencers to spread
propaganda
um the white house countered holding by
the way it wasn't even like they flew
people to dc they did a zoom briefing
about ukraine for 30 tick-tock stars
like that that's the whole story that's
the whole story
and it says that national security
council staffers and gensake
uh gave updates
and um i mean it's it's almost like a
just kind of like a non-story
um
and there has been significant use of
tick-tock
by
apparent russian propaganda
nodes i guess we would call them
to spread uh just so doubt about the
innocence of ukraine in the context of
the invasion etc and as is often the
case with a lot of these right wingers
if they spent
10 of the time that they spent lying
about what democrats are doing
ten percent of that time
working to actually fix a problem
the country would be
dramatically better off and this is one
of the great frustrations which is we
see the clip it's 23 seconds of marjorie
taylor green uh lying about biden paying
off tick-tock influencers
and we debunk it pretty quickly it's
just it's not true it was a zoom meeting
no one was paid that's all it was great
we've established that
but we are constantly kind of playing
catch-up in the sense that there are
real problems to solve here even when it
comes to russia and ukraine
what is going to be the long-term
economic impact what should be the u.s
perspective
as we become accustomed to the invasion
as you can already see there's less
coverage of it even now the invasion's
still going on
but once a story gets stretched out you
start to see less coverage
or different types of coverage and so
what should be the continued attitude
and media coverage and sanction
framework and all these different things
and these are real things to figure out
what about ukrainian refugees
what about arming ukraine but stopping
short of the line that biden drew which
is troops on the ground these are all
serious important things
and marjorie taylor green is out there
saying biden's paying tick-tockers and
it's just a flat out and complete lie
and
i i hate to use that tired phrase this
is why we can't have nice things
but
in a in a literal sense the fact that
these are conversations that have to be
pushed back against or these are these
are lies that have to be pushed back
against
there's only 24 hours in a day and
people got to sleep right and and so
by having to say none of this stuff is
happening in order to protect the
reputation of the people that are
actually working hard to try to solve
problems
we lose time
and resources and just headspace to
actually deal with those problems and
it's a very sad thing
let me know your thoughts you can find
me on twitter at deepakman also make
sure that you are following us on tiktok
where you can find us at david pakman's
show we are doing
separate tick-tock only updates
on the russian invasion of ukraine which
you can follow there we'll take a quick
break and be back with a
very packed friday show for you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show does depend on the
support of listeners and viewers like
you through what we call the membership
program we do an extra show every day
for our members and provide all sorts of
other great perks and benefits you can
sign up at joinpacman.com
you can also use the coupon code wow22
if you so please let's hear from some
folks from the audience we had some
beautiful calls last week we take calls
via discord which you can find at
davidpakman.com
discord let's go next to ellie from
seattle ellie you're on the air
hi david thanks for taking my call
pleasure
um
i
i feel like with um the don't say gay um
the legislation that it just passed in
florida and there's a number of
like anti-trans bills uh across the
country i feel like we're watching a
very slow train wreck
um and i want to know how do we stop it
yeah i would say it's not even
necessarily that slow and it's all being
driven by
local elected officials and like we've
been saying for a very long time
you have to control
governorships
and state senates and state legislatures
and when you don't these are the types
of things that happen and the danger
level
is exacerbated because we know that we
have one of the most conservative
supreme courts in a very very long time
even if judge jackson replaces stephen
breyer it doesn't change the balance of
the court it's still a very conservative
court and so there's the additional risk
that one or two states will have some of
these uh bills um challenged all the way
up to the supreme court and upheld and
then it's going to be open season in
every red state so i i think this is a
this is the combination of about half a
dozen different failures
yeah and we're probably looking at row
going to the supreme court too maybe so
maybe so yeah yeah that's not it's not
at all uh
impossible
completely plausible that that will
happen
and uh you know i mean i can't there's
no one thing ellie that there is to
blame for this you know it's like yes
democrats have not done enough at the
state level
uh yes all these different things but
also remember ellie the people in 2016
who said supreme court picks i don't
care i don't care whether it's trump and
hillary we would not be in this
situation right now
where hillary clinton the winner in 2016
and had hillary clinton been able to
select some supreme court justices we
just wouldn't be in this situation
yeah absolutely
is there i mean
you said it's not even necessarily a
slow train wreck is there anything that
we can do to mitigate it
we i mean listen there's elections in
november
what can be done at the state level in
november how many governorships can can
be taken from republicans
how many legislatures or state senates
can be taken from republicans and i
don't know the answer i don't have the
the data in front of me but it's not
just about
senate and house of representatives
nationally we've got to be doing better
at the state level and it's just it's
it's embarrassing quite frankly
absolutely well thank you david ellie
from seattle thank you so much for the
call
a disturbing situation a disturbing
situation let's go next to john from is
it pronounced lester is that the correct
pronunciation
yeah no it's a lester we spoke before
actually i remember in question i
remember i always want to get because in
the us
there are towns in the u.s with the same
spelling but we call them leicester
that's fair i mean i used to call things
like that because i'm from south wales
so you probably i don't know if you've
noticed in my accent i do different most
gang from most english people i almost
pressed left bro luca when i first came
here and people laugh which is fair like
but
well that's a whole other story probably
yeah
yeah i get really i wanted to talk to
you about i guess like mainly the i
guess the current political climate i
don't know maybe i've been naive over
these last couple of years but i guess i
don't know maybe you're about as worried
as i am about the overall rise in uh
right wing opinions against the pro
typical fascists
and how that affects our current like i
guess western outlook it sounds like i'm
at least as worried as you i mean we
have a few different things going on
first of all you have the rise of
right-wing
uh hyper or super nationalism and we've
seen that in a number of european
countries we're seeing it to some degree
in south america we're seeing it in a
lot of different places in addition to
that trump in the u.s
pulled a ton of people who were not
previously engaged with politics into
the political space and they're they're
almost exclusively horrible people and
some of them are like remaining involved
for now now depending on what happens
here in the u.s in november they may
become uh unengaged or disheartened and
we'll have to wait and see
but you then combine that
with the effect of the radicalizing
effect of social media's filter bubbles
and echo chambers which serves to
reinforce these radical beliefs and all
of it together is a recipe for exactly
the disaster that you're pointing out
i guess as well i guess is it hard to
hide right now at least because
currently from a british perspective the
influence as well of other powers on our
i guess electoral systems i mean already
now people are starting to talk in the
uk about how much russia had an effect
on the brexit vote right which was
invariably driven by people's vitriol
towards uh immigrants i can say that
like leicester was the only part of the
east midlands that voted to remain the
rest all the other counties that would
leave leicester's proportionality wise
it's quite a diverse city it's quite
nice to live in but the county is it's
like 99.94 white british leicester 40
white british and then we pretty much i
think representation from 110 out of 140
or so nations in the world
what is the population of leicester
oh about 300k i reckon i've got a
million in the leicester leicestershire
area oh i should know these things i do
i've managed clinical projects in the
nhs that's very interesting and now you
mentioned white british
in
your area
is there a distinction made between
white british and like say french or
italian folks
i think so and again it depends on
probably the person you ask i think if
you can ask somebody for you ask me i'd
probably talk more demographically be
able to speak to somebody who's i guess
like had more traditionalist values
let's say um they probably would
actually differentiate then again
further and go you know these people
eastern european they're western
european this is a i i it's quite a
quite tricky situation in the uk a lot
of people have a lot of hatred towards
people particularly of eastern european
origin that's right
yeah i mean you know one of the
interesting things in the united states
is that the definition of who's
considered white has changed over time
you know there was a period where darker
skinned southern italians were not
considered white now i think there are
very few people that would argue that
they are not white but then there's
questions as to whether you know our are
persians white and white supremacists
say well jews are not white all these
different things it is very interesting
how that changes and it sounds like at
least where you are
there's there's still at least a
significant portion that sees
non-british western europeans as
something a little different at least
absolutely and like i think it's
definitely what bro drove a lot of
people to vote leave is this idea an
antagonistic view of it were towards i
guess people outside of britain
yeah i can't even escape but as a welsh
person i've never really been one for
nationalism but i mean yeah
enjoy the difference between a welsh
national english nationalist the
language they speak last thing as a
welsh gentleman
how closely do you identify
sort of with like the london milieu and
culture like do you feel like that's
kind of what you're part of or do you
really feel like like you're in a very
different area
you have to ask me about london it's my
least favorite city you know absolutely
but i mean i guess what i'm trying to
get to is culturally do you feel like
you like lester and london are part of
the same thing or that it's really
different
i say it's similar but different i think
it's similar in the sense that it is
quite a diverse city and it is quite
metropolitan it's different in the level
of i guess access to public services and
healthcare like this is you know it's in
east midlands city because of the lack
of services whereas in london i guess
well london's always considered the
utopia when you speak to people it's the
london lifestyle and then the others i
like russia moscow i think
yeah i mean there's some in france
there's a lot of paris and then
everything else and then the folks in
brittany often think of themselves as
different as well that's yeah the
internal dynamics are interesting
because from far away like in the us
people just tend to have a sense of oh
there's france and then there's the uk
and then there's italy but within these
countries there are such dramatic
differences
absolutely i absolutely couldn't agree
more like no thanks for taking my
questions there all right john thank you
great to hear from you again
all right john from lester
what a call
uh very very exciting there for sure
let's go
next to julius from idaho julius you're
on the air
all right can you hear me yes i can
alright so i was just wondering um
do you think the ukraine war isn't
okay so you cut out we what we heard you
say was do i think the ukraine get away
with taking care of its citizens what we
heard when you cut out was do i think
the ukraine war and then you cut out so
do what what was the rest of the
question do i think the ukraine war what
do you think the ukraine war is an
excuse for the us to get away with
taking care of its citizens um just you
know regular bernie sanders policies
no i'm not sure i even understand the
question is the ukraine war
oh an excuse for who to get away with it
the u.s like they're politicians um
like i'm saying like so for example if
biden were to legalize marijuana which
he isn't okay do you think he can still
just get away with not
legalizing marijuana because they're
like focusing on the ukraine war
no i think he was going to be able to
get away with it regardless i don't
think he had any and remember the real
discussion was decriminalization as far
as biden's concerned uh i don't think he
was ever really interested in it and i
think he'll be able to get away with not
doing it regardless of what's happening
in ukraine
okay no all right thank you all right
thank you for the call there's julius
from idaho
let's go next to fiona from germany
fiona welcome
fiona from germany please unmute you're
on the air
and last chance for fiona from germany
to unmute you're on the air but you must
have working
hello fiona
hello how are you i'm
fine thank you sorry about my audio it
sometimes doesn't like changing channels
would
be interested in what's like your
opinion on the german
reinvestment into military because i'm
concerned about what my government does
with talking so little to each other let
alone the general public you know
yeah i have to tell you it's not a big
shock to me that there's renewed
interest in investment in a larger
military in germany to be perfectly
honest and i think the reasons for that
are
one is a more longer-term reason and one
is more short-term
after seeing the way that the trump
presidency caused a rift with germany
which is historically in recent decades
such a great ally of the united states
it seems
logical now i don't i'm not saying i
love everybody having bigger militaries
but i'm just saying from the german
perspective
if all of a sudden
you're not quite so friendly with like
one of your big allies that also has
this massive military which is the
united states it seems completely
sensible that you would say hey we
should probably just have a bigger
military given that we don't know what
sorts of needs we might have that we
need to go go it alone for
uh if there's another trump where we're
all of a sudden not getting along so
well or the american president can't be
relied upon or is just a loose cannon so
that that to me makes a lot of sense as
to why it would make germany have a
renewed interest in having a stronger
military does that make sense
some would but i would have expected
that it would be a more european
approach especially since we still rely
on the french president to say whatever
our military is going to do like two
weeks in advance okay yeah but uh i
think that it
in even if you consider it a european
interest
i would include france in this as well i
mean all all of these western european
countries
suffered a situation during trump's four
years
where all of a sudden the u.s
was a different sort of ally than
previous to trump so it it does make a
lot of sense to me
i do get that but like
declaring national budget to me was
disturbing like
the same time it was also announced that
germany would just like put some troops
in reserve for the european commission
to uh have
emergency access to
which i believe would have been
more popular with the german general
public than
just like throwing double the annual
budget on the military ones yeah i don't
disagree with you and i'm not saying i
like it i'm just saying that thinking
about it from a geopolitical perspective
i i understand it i think the other
thing also is uh there's probably some
degree to which the russian invasion of
ukraine
is making a lot of countries just kind
of reevaluate um
their military capabilities and it
wouldn't be surprising to me that that
might also push some militaries or some
countries to want to strengthen the
military either although that's more of
a short term hopefully a short-term
thing
thanks for taking my question my
pleasure fiona from germany what a call
what a call let's go next to barry
from milwaukee barry welcome
uh hi david can you hear me yes i can
yeah uh i had a question if you were you
know canvassing in milwaukee or
wisconsin one of these swing states
and you were talking to a voter and you
were saying this is the biggest
accomplishment of the biden
administration what would you bring up
i mean so here's the thing about it i
think right now there's a few of what i
would consider the major biden
accomplishments and it would depend on
who i'm talking to so i would need to
know more about what a wisconsin voter
is likely to care about
but i would say that the infrastructure
package the vaccine rollout
coveted stimulus and getting out of
afghanistan would be the four big
accomplishments
once judge jackson is confirmed to the
court and i believe she will be i would
also uh add that to the list as the five
big biden accomplishments so far but
which one i would list depends on who
i'm talking to and what i believe they
care about right
yeah i mean like that that makes sense
uh i just what i wanted to put on your
radar because you know i've been doing
voter outreach in the state for
a few years now it's just like
knocking doors right now and phone calls
are very hard people
are plugged out are very negative and so
i'm i'm worried about
uh the possible wins we could have in
the future for the next couple of years
right well listen i mean one at this
point seeing the three supreme court
justices that trump got and now that joe
biden is getting one
i can't imagine
any only the most kind of depraved bury
your head in the sand
democrats at this point would fail to
see
imagine if hillary had gotten those
three supreme court picks okay and think
about
roe v wade might go away
look at what's happening with all of
these different issues that now are
going to the supreme court and we have
one of the most right-wing courts we've
had in a really long time
just think back how this would have been
different if hillary had won and that
should really remind us of when joe
biden now gets one pick
the people who wrote off the supreme
court is an irrelevant issue wow wow i
hope that they feel ashamed for ashamed
of themselves
you know david that that's that's
actually was really helpful in
motivating me to you know keep at it
thank you thank you all right very good
uh uh keep yes absolutely keep at it um
let's take a quick break we're going to
keep taking calls so don't hang up if
you're holding we're just taking a very
quick break and then we'll be right back
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow let's go back to the
audience on our discord if you'd like to
call in you can go to davidpakman.com
discord
let's speak next to harrison from
california harrison you are on the air
welcome
hey david thanks for having me my
pleasure
um i didn't really come with a specific
question other than um just to share
uh frustration uh not too long ago
actually i think it was the other night
i watched a clip of yours uh where
someone asked about how your
girlfriend communicates with a
largely conservative family
and it resonated with me i have um both
my parents whom are separated
uh
have over the past six years
been just completely inundated with
the conservative the typical
conservative talking points you know you
name it from fox news to uh
um you know tucker caller
carlson
to um you know my my mom who's always
been more
conservative
but
she has
turned into like she's just gone
straight down the rabbit hole to the
point where
you know she sends me stuff and she's on
like telegram with these
uh q and on people and i'm just like
i try to say like look
you need to get rid of this she there's
no ability she has no ability to tell
right from wrong and i mean the most
ironic thing is when i bring counter
points up she gives my points more
scrutiny and criticism than
the points that other people are telling
her she just like accepts you know it's
typical i expect it accepting the things
that agree with her and you know things
that she doesn't agree with hey let me
ask you this what what kind of what
field does she work in
um
she's she's been in sales a lot but uh
she's like a
like in kind of like the
real estate kind of thing right now it
does she seem to have an ability to
think critically in within the field of
real estate
in other words when people make claims
about
oh look it looks like you've got a
termite damage no no no no we don't it's
fine that's actually nothing she like is
she's able to discern that like people
might be lying there or is does she
generally is she generally naive
uh generally generally i mean it's more
of a like happy-go-lucky person and i
mean it's worked for you know she's a
kind-hearted person like in reality but
the one thing is you know she's uh
like a little bit of her background her
and her family my my uh
parents and aunts and uncles
grandparents ran away from communism uh
in from china
um and it for so for that reason their
whole journey to get to america back you
know in the 50s and 60s like 50s and 60s
um really you know is what got them
really patriotic and and really
appreciate the country which is
something that
when i was growing up really you know
made me kind of proud and and uh
you know stuff like that but it always
gave
you know my my family's pretty split so
half of it is a little more liberal half
half is a little more conservative
and um
she like she does exhibit a little bit
of
like critical thinking when it matters
but i mean at the same time like i
couldn't you know if she went to take
her car in to get fixed like
she'd probably get ripped off to tell
you to be the truth like i'm usually
have to be the one to be like okay wait
wait wait like does this actually need
to happen i can actually do this so
it sounds like sort of maybe there's
just the personality predisposition to
sort of accept what people are saying in
some way and it's not just on politics
yeah there there is a predisposition and
that's why i feel like she's more
of a victim of the
the whole you know narrative that
they're trying to pitch because she's
definitely someone when i was growing up
you know the am radio is always on
always talking to r like uh rush
limbaugh or like listening to all these
shows yeah and she would come home from
work and like the first things out of
her mouth was just you know oh my god
obama's gonna do this you know uh
this and that that little you know
they're gonna try and take over the
country and like it's it's not that bad
it's i've literally been sitting through
30 years of the sky is falling
essentially about you know
liberalism and i was i was in the marine
corps for for seven years and so i you
know i get the the concern you know
patriotic conservative standing
standpoints and just only really over
the past like five years
have i really just kind of turned and
been like you know that there's really
nothing
that
you know
insane that's happening
on this side like this there there are
like crazy ideas but there's crazy ideas
on both sides and the stuff that ends up
getting executed and assigned into
action
really are pretty mild at the end of the
day hey in the marine corps were there
any progressives or was it very very
conservative
it's it's largely conservative
absolutely um there are like i i've met
quite a few
like rational level-headed people they
might still fall on the conservative
spectrum and
um
but there there definitely are like i
mean it's probably i would say some of
the best people i've met have been the
ones that have ended up being a little
more like moderate to
to liberal
like in political view and that's not
just by like me asking them like hey
what are you but it's just their
personality showed it which is what you
know why we became great friends and
then later on i was like oh hey like you
know after getting to know them like hey
he's actually kind of
you know rational thinking in the
military but it's definitely a minority
well harrison you've really said it all
i i appreciate it sounds like a
complicated situation but i wish you the
best
i appreciate you taking the time to talk
to me all right harrison from california
that's quite a scene that's for sure i
would not uh
that that's complicated
let's go next to pablo from albuquerque
pablo you're on the air
just barely pablo you're barely audible
it sounds like you're about two miles
from your microphone is there anything
you can do
all right we're gonna have to let pablo
go unfortunately it's we've never had a
caller so so quiet you know who we
haven't spoken to for a while our other
cancun caller it's bit defender
bitdefender welcome
hey david hello
how are you
i'm fine excellent what's on your mind
today
um i was listening enjoying your monday
theme show
about critical race theory and there was
a point in the show in which you
mentioned how
angry
and how mad
people got at these
rallies and events
i do believe there's
some element of
heightened
anger
you know republicans seem more prone to
outrage in this sense um i think because
of the culture war but that's beside the
point okay the question is
given that
anger and stress
usually have negative health
consequences
and this is a bit of a random question
do you think maybe in the future we will
see
um
you know statistically significant
enough
differences in health outcomes by
political ideology well we already might
what's so there's a very interesting
thing about that which is
the red states on average have worse
health care systems and lower uh life
expectancy it's it's already the case
now
there's a real question as to whether
within those states
there's a difference in life expectancy
based on political ideology but like for
example mississippi which is one of the
reddest states has very bad healthcare
and
you know connecticut which is a very
blue state has very good healthcare so
we already see that
the the counterbalance is
i believe it's still true that
conservatives on average have more kids
than liberals so you could i mean it's
it's complicated math but you could have
a situation where
the the republicans have lower life
expectancy but they're reproducing more
quickly and that allows them to keep
winning elections it's it's it's
we need more data to answer the question
but it's an interesting one
well i i mean i don't know about
um
influencing electoral outcomes yeah you
know which one is mostly yeah like
individual health outcomes on average
uh given the externalities of stress and
you know heightened negative emotion
right
yeah i mean it's a question that we just
need data to answer and it's data that i
don't have the data we do have though is
that on average life expectancy is
longer in blue states and it would stand
to reason that if you extrapolated that
out
on average on average you may well be
right that leftists have a slightly
longer life expectancy than right
wingers by virtue of where they live not
because of their ideology you're asking
a more specific question but but i think
it's a fascinating one i don't know the
answer
you know it's one of those questions
that pop into your mind um because you
you
you know you know you you are a busy
person you live stress on a daily basis
i guess
um
i suppose you can tell that it does take
a toll on your health
um i can't imagine what it would be to
live
in a
world in which
you know
most of the
republican beliefs are well certainly
true for them you know yeah um but yeah
anyway that that was my question thank
you very much david hey how how are it's
been years since i've been to cancun how
are things there right now
well you know the city keeps growing um
big
urban problems keep uh you know
happening you keep popping up with this
is a city for that was originally
designed for 250 000 people and we're
breaking 1.1 million i think wow uh you
know there's there's
issues related to that a lot a lot of um
wealth inequality between the planned
part of the city and the new parts
for you know various different reasons
related to government
um
[Music]
someone who lives there do you do you
ever go to the hotel zone or do do
locals never go to that area oh i work
at the hotel zone oh you work there oh
okay all right
well how about for people who are who
live there and don't work in the hotel
zone do they ever go to the hotel zone
yeah yeah so
think of it like
you live in new york i think think of it
like the the the
nicer part of town that it's not
downtown you know it's like where the
very high-end restaurants are
it's where um
usually very affluent people will just
usually just live you know like they
will eat the work and sleep in the hotel
zone
you know in incidences and whatnot but
yeah and
you will see a big wealth difference
here between the people that live here
and the people that work
got it got it got it
all right well i appreciate the call
great to hear from you again thank you
david all right there's bit defender
strongly defending bits in cancun
let's go to dar from moscow now is this
moscow russia or moscow idaho
dar you're on the air please unmute
and last opportunity for dar from moscow
so curious is it moscow russia we may
never know if dar can not unmute
too bad too bad i real that was the
would have been very interesting if it
was russia
um let's go to robert from san diego
robert you're on the air
hello hey how are you
oh you can hear me
yes
wow amazing i've i've been it's been a
long time
tried to be on the show
um i'm just trying to be
i i have
i first i want to say that i have some
mental illness some problems i want to
make you to help me to make sure that i
am calm and capable because i'm talking
you're doing great okay
okay first i i i started watching your
program um
sometime last year i really admire it
your ability to stay calm and collected
is just amazing thank you
especially with people you know all
these controversial figures
i just wanted to um
give you my um perspective a little and
have one little question for you i'm
gonna try to make it quick now robert
just in the interest of time and because
your discord is blinging up a storm
maybe for today we could get right to
the question
okay
yes oh my right to the question i have
been watching belarus for years and
years and years and i've known and for
now i've know i've known
what our autocracy really is my question
for you is do you how many
how many
how long do you think trumpist would
like
trump to be president
you know what i think it depends on
which ones
yeah i mean gosh i think that there are
trumpists who if they thought trump
could keep winning
would say there should be no term limits
on they would say listen if we want to
keep electing him why shouldn't he be
allowed to just stay in the white house
i don't think that applies to all
trumpists though to all of them yeah
oh okay no because with me watching that
i was i was always wondering about
that i was thinking oh my gosh that
would be a nightmare no you're
completely right that there are
trumpists who would say
there's no reason for term limits we
think trump could keep winning and he
should just stay in for as long as
people want him not all of them but some
of them
oh yeah okay
robert thank you for the call i really
appreciate it you've done a great job
and uh let's hope to hear from more
people in the future that's gonna do it
for today as always we can't ever take
every call
but we will take calls again very soon
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
it's time for the weekly mailbag if you
have something you want to say to me and
many of you do
you can email info davidpakman.com
please don't abuse it but you can do
that you can email info davidpakman.com
let's get right in we're going to start
with a very very ugly message this one
actually came in via facebook this was a
response to
our clip last week about evolution you
might remember that republican senate
candidate herschel walker last week said
if evolution is real why are there still
monkeys
and we talked about that last week now
this viewer wrote to me
very angry
making the following counterpoint think
about water
were
did it came from or did it also evolved
and you know i never have considered the
evolution of water in this entire
crazy thing we called life i don't i
don't have an answer to that
um this person also went on two hours
later to write and say as a follow-up in
all caps
jehovah is the name of the creator
whether you believe it or not just
because you may not like it doesn't mean
is not
true
so uh quite a diatribe
from
the standpoint of the evolution of water
and this of course a reminder that
education is really a problem in the
united states if we had a solution to
the education problem um we would be
much better off politically we would be
much better off culturally and we would
be much better off economically i would
argue so there it is the evolution of
water not something i had thought about
before
john wrote in
and john said hey pacman or pac-man
whatever
i am expressing my opinion here as a
viewer
you have a horrible stupid show
stop broadcasting now
stop wasting your time
get a real life
and grow up uh i actually i love these
emails the and the reason i love these
emails and i know there are people in
our audience who like the show and who
are miserable in their jobs and i don't
take any pleasure in that i like that
makes me feel bad i want everybody to
have a job they like and that's
sustainable financially and all these
different things
one of the things i love is people who
are very clearly not satisfied with
their own lives
write to me and say
you gotta get a real job you gotta you
gotta get a real life you've gotta grow
up etc this job is fine i i love the
hours
uh i'm very satisfied with the salary
i'm very satisfied with the meaning of
what i'm doing and it's just so funny to
hear from other people who are clearly
miserable in their lives which in many
cases is what causes them to lash out at
random people on the internet that they
don't know
uh
there's something funny
about them saying to me
you gotta get your life together
together kid
so anyway thank you john i appreciate
the the message okay
p samuels wrote in this is the last
negative one then we're gonna go to
positive and substantive stuff i very
seldom write to shows on tv or otherwise
i guess i'm lucky in that way
david pakman
is a true low iq imbecile
do us all a favor and ask him
to keep his mouth shut
there is so much dribble coming forth
from his mouth
it is beyond disgusting well
thank you sir i will keep that in mind i
guess i should really reconsider
this show it seems like at least two
people
very very much don't like it that's p
samuels all right let's get into some
other stuff
um oh
sorry i apologize there's one more
negative one and this this so here's the
point with this one
uh we covered trump's last rallyings
excuse me choking here i'm going to take
a sip of water
we covered trump's last rally in south
carolina
and i mentioned on twitter
that trump was particularly disheveled
slurring
confused both eyes almost completely
swollen shut
and it seemed that a lot of his
followers realized it was not a great
performance
but they decided to take it out on me
they were furious with me
for my commentary on the rally
newpont wrote to me and said about the
rally
david you are disgusting
you are an arrogant ignorant fool
sucking up to the likes of nancy pelosi
chuck schumer the squad and the rest of
the socialist elite in washington now
what i love about that
is i'm not a fan of nancy pelosi's
i can't remember the last time i spoke
about chuck schumer
i can't remember the last time i praised
the squad and i'm not a socialist so i
actually don't know what this person's
talking about but doesn't matter here's
the amazing part of the email i watched
the trump rally
the man is brilliant
you are an idiot and a fool and your
snide little snippets during the
president's presentation exuded and
reeked of your ignorance and arrogance
go drown yourself in the swamp of
washington dc i have never watched your
show had never even heard of you until i
watched this rally on your channel and i
will never ever in the history of the
world watch you again you are a sick man
here's what i would say to you sir
anyone who believes trump is brilliant
should not like my show i would consider
it a problem i would be concerned if
someone who thinks trump is brilliant
liked what i was doing it i consider it
praise it is confirmation that i'm doing
something right
that people who think trump is brilliant
don't like me that's a great thing thank
you sir i appreciate that okay david
wrote in with some ideas for an
alternative to screed
back in february i would often describe
trump's unhinged rants as febrile
screeds david wrote in and said i've
noticed you keep referring to various
wacky or delusional rants by right-wing
politicians as screeds for example
donald trump's latest febrile screed
perhaps a distinction without a
difference but technically screed refers
to a written rant not a spoken one as
you mean to say there are a number of
alternatives you can test out including
diatribe
tirade and polemic
in all seriousness thanks for calling
out the buffoonery of these right-wing
radicals when they issue such febrile
screeds
with peace and love yeah i had something
like for march since it has an m
uh i i think i i was it was a manic
what was it manic i don't remember now
anyway i'll work on something else uh
maybe a uh
maybe a delusional diatribe would be
some appropriate alliteration
another david wrote in dave who says
david you mentioned that the democracy
rating of ukraine is 60 and russia is
20. where does the united states fit on
the same scale so
that particular ranking was from the
freedom house
and in that freedom house index the u.s
ranks at an 82
on the democracy
rank ranking so in that one it's us-82
ukraine 60 russia 20.
now i think that there is a case to be
made
that
in the united states
people are less free than in some other
countries in a particular way and that
is the ability
to live your life the way you want
without worrying about having medical
coverage
that's not typically considered in most
of these kind of like freedom and
democracy rankings
i would argue and i would argue it very
strongly
that
if you
know that no matter what you do you have
medical care
you are more free to pursue
a passion that may not come with health
insurance and the job that you would
tend to have to have to get health
insurance you are free to
stay home and raise children without
having to worry about will i have health
insurance so that's not typically part
of these freedom and democracy rankings
i believe it should be because in
countries where you are guaranteed
health care regardless of your job you
are more free in a sense although i
understand that it's a little bit
different than issues of corruption and
the like but in the freedom house index
uh the u.s ranks at 82
compared to ukraine 60 and russia 20.
brian writes in and says i have enjoyed
watching some of your youtube pieces i
have a suggestion
say electoral
instead of electoral
see what you think keep calm and carry
on so i again i look this up and this is
going to relate to a later
a later email
i am finding that both pronunciations
electoral and electoral
are both appropriate
electoral comes more naturally to me and
i don't know if it's that i i speak
english as a second language or what but
electoral
just feels more natural okay sherry
wrote in asking is the white house
beautiful or is it a dump
david go back and look at videos from
when trump first won in 2016 and went to
the white house he called the white
house a dump now he says it's beautiful
the beautiful white house what a schmuck
he is as bad as hitler disgusting human
being thanks keep up the good work yeah
i mean listen the guy's a total
hypocrite um the you know putin's good
or putin's bad ukraine's good or
ukraine's bad he will uh build the wall
or not or he'll replace obamacare or he
won't or it's it
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
he says
we don't really know what he believes i
believe he basically believes nothing he
believes whatever is convenient to say
at the time
but uh yeah and i actually remember the
opposite also because there were times
while trump was there
that he called the white house beautiful
and then now that biden's there
says that it's a dump and it's been
disgraced or whatever sherry i just
wouldn't worry about it don't worry
about what trump says on the white house
last email is from kate
kate says you might want to be careful
citing a dictionary as a prescriptive
reference this is a common error a
dictionary is a descriptive tool not a
prescriptive one it describes the
language that existed at the time of
publication using the dictionary to say
the dictionary says x means y isn't
helpful the dictionary doesn't tell
people what to use now it tells you what
people used then well i mean listen
that's totally fair when i say
i looked up the acceptable
pronunciations of such a word and here's
what the dictionary says you could say
well those were acceptable at the time
the dictionary was written but i think
that that actually sort of goes to my
point which is absent that
then any pronunciation would be
acceptable because at the end of the day
it's just what people are doing it would
be you you would better be able to
justify no no the
pronunciation of electoral is
appropriate because it's what i use
it's kind of an endless loop so i think
when it comes to accepted pronunciations
it i i think it's okay to look at the
dictionary um
but i do understand how
looking at the dictionary for
definitions like you know when jesse lee
peterson said to me what is a man
the dictionary may not reflect
the political and cultural realities of
the time i think that that's fair
and i appreciate the comment from kate
we have a great voice we have a great
bonus show coming up you can sign up at
joinpacman.com to get instant access
we will see you then